[Music]
the Children's Hospital Association and
the American Academy of Pediatrics are
calling on President Biden to declare a
Health Emergency due to unprecedented
levels of respiratory and flu infections
a Biden official says the administration
is quote ready to provide assistance to
communities who are in need of help on a
case-by-case basis here to react is Fox
News medical contributor Dr Marty McCary
so Dr welcome and let's just get right
first into the RSV situation many people
believe that immunities have been
suppressed that people's immune systems
have been suppressed because of the
vaccine do you think that that is
contributing to this situation with RSV
I do Rachel and a lot of doctors believe
in the concept of immunity debt that is
when you're virus naive for a long
period of time when you're sheltered
your body's not getting that low level
of viral exposure that builds immunity
at a low level and it may be subclinical
you may not notice it so that's probably
why we're seeing seeing this massive
influx of RSV and influenza and other
infections right now accounting for
hospitalizations in children our
ferment the health
are they saying that very clearly
this is because of the vaccine or is
this just something doctors know but
nobody is officially saying it because
it's maybe Politically Incorrect
look there's not a lot of support for
saying something like that right now in
the world of censorship and the medical
establishment but many immunologists
have written about this Monica Gandhi
and others infectious diseases
Specialists and it's well known the
concept of immunity debt so this may be
one of the consequences of the lockdown
that we have not yet measured and we're
seeing these hospitalizations in Mass
numbers right now we're talking 90 to 95
percent of hospitalizations in children
for infections are not for covid they're
for other infections right now what is
all of this doing to The credibility of
Public Health and also the American
Medical Association the pediatric
medical association but you say their
leaders are activists and they are
disconnected from their members while
the American Academy of Pediatrics lost
a lot of credibility in being bystanders
in the school closures and insisting
that every child wear a mask for two
years covering their faces and now we're
dealing with a mental health crisis and
lifelong learning loss so many
pediatricians have stopped paying their
dues to the American Academy of
Pediatrics remember a survey showed that
40 percent of pediatric pediatricians in
America did not recommend the covet
vaccine for young healthy children that
shows the massive disconnect with the
activist leadership of the American
Academy Dr McCary you showed courage
when it counted I wish many of those
doctors that aren't paying their dues
had let their voices be heard when it
actually counted I want to move really
quickly to another topic researchers say
that there may be a vaccine for fentanyl
a drug that is 100 times stronger than
morphine your thoughts on that yeah this
is interesting research from Houston
there's actually this idea that if you
give the vaccine antibodies could
develop to fentanyl making them molecule
larger and then it cannot enter the
blood-brain barrier and have as much of
an effect so this is interesting it may
make fentanyl a little safer but
remember when you make drugs a little
more safer people push that risk level
and risk appeals to some people that's
why the best strategy is that no drug is
safe and we can't just
sort of promote the moral hazard of a
safer drug yeah probably the solution is
to close the southern border where so
much fentanyl is coming from Dr Marty
McCary my favorite truth teller in the
medical establishment or not really the
medical establishment but in the medical
field so thank you so much for joining
us thanks Rachel you got it I'm Steve
Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley
Earhart and click here to subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis